all right cool so Nick is using the
PlayStation Move controllers uh where
are you about is this like kind of tour
the beginning or this is this is after
you've escaped from Heligan okay start
in the game this is actually where we
would present a lot of Skyrim demos six
years ago
okay I'm showing you off yeah everything
you can see you can go to those
mountains in the distance now you can
experience all the VR it's the game you
know and love it's you know doom was a
different experience from doom 2016 this
is Skyrim this is everything in Skyrim
and the world exists as we remember it
to in like a little bit reworked I'm
sure visually for yeah I mean even if
like something subtle like if he twists
his arm and and moves the sword around
like you never were looking at the your
weapons kind of from all angles yeah
yeah if you pull up magic now the
ability to kind of cast in any direction
yeah you want is something that's I
think remarkable to do and play an
experience it just you kind of feel like
you are just amazing one of my first
character build in Skyrim and back in
2012 was kind of a spelling one hand
sword and the other kind of thing that
seemed super appealing yeah I would
always be flames and sword yeah or
restoration and flames
yeah and and now it's just like I just
want to try everything now with with the
Move controllers to go through this was
actually a like that kind of had a WoW
moment when I was looking at this in VR
cuz just that the sense of scale you get
when you look up in the world the skybox
so yeah I think it's pretty great
feeling so I forgot what someone back
when the game came out they timed how
long it took to walk from like the east
end of Skyrim to the West and I think
it's like 40 minutes or maybe more I've
heard something like that yeah I guess
it depends you know how much armor
you've got on you right yeah what your
stamina and I wonder if just like I mean
I'm sure in VR it just implies that
sense of scale so much more and kind of
just like you're the actual distance
you're traveling feels so much more you
know like yeah you do you feel like
you're you're really just trekking
through that yep next to all the
universes everything you want to be are
stuff this is the mature rated stream
yeah it's a little yeah
to me and so I was asking this before so
this my cool is going here you go ahead
you need the Move controllers or the
vive ones so there's there's three main
controlled mechanics we have the one
that Nick's doing right now is with the
move and it with the left move button
pressing that in he can then point in
the direction he wants to move okay so
it gives a very smooth movement with his
right hand there I think it's the X and
O buttons he can pivot the camera about
15 20 degrees to really make sure you
can direct himself to where he needs to
go obviously the head tracking plays in
the other move playstation notes hold
little triangle on the right-hand for 2
seconds that'll Crouch you to Lane in
you blew it I know yeah we have this on
a novice right now so if they go down
pretty quickly don't give yourself too
much yeah what's actually done anybody
else in the room steer clear of Nick
because he is flowing yeah so then we
have the teleportation controlled
mechanic okay and then if if you kind of
need a break he's standing up obviously
right now if you just kind of want to
experience Skyrim like you're used to
you can sit on the couch use a DualShock
and just use the headset for kind of the
immersive factor right Nick you've got
one headphone in but how does it sound
does it sound like you're in the cave it
right after I mean I played this game
three or four times and like a bunch of
different consoles this is so cool
because I've been here before and I
actually feel like I'm physically inside
what's yet actually what's really cool
if you go forward because it looks like
there's some light passing through in
the pit or maybe that's steam any any
place like the the first time you enter
bleak falls Barrow and you kind of see
the light passing in or you're at the
end of a cave and you can see the light
casting out that you really have a sense
of like oh I'm actually here right that
uh bleep balls but for me was the moment
where I was kind of just stopped playing
Skyrim like I was playing scar
and said I'm actually going to look
around share and see what the world
looks like that I can smell the roses
exactly yeah Nick when you're uh I'm
assuming his character has like fire or
I can equip that if you want whatever
you want I can't want to see the spells
sure huh okay so I want to comes up as
kind of like a hovering Oh triangle or
circle actually on the left hand oh so
that's your favorites panel menu when
you hit circle it's just kind of
Minority Report down by holding the
trigger with your left hand two flames
one more and then hit the move button on
both I like getting my hands up on both
hit circle and back out of there and
yeah so now you can you can twist and
turn your hands how everyone and just
start thinking apart I always joke about
it it's very cool yeah wait point it
yourself where are these oh that's hot
yeah that is super weird to see because
like I was always the fixed point they
were going towards yeah yeah
and so actually our producer loaded me
in a save without telling me what I was
about to see you there was a dragon in
front of me and a pear and it was this
oh crap moment and like immediately I
instinctively kind of went like this and
he's passing in one direction pass over
right kind of do a little point on how
do you can down yeah yeah you know just
up the hands together you got a girl
actually so if you notice there when he
looks down that the quest compass is now
below an irrelevant information like
Health's Avenue right Attica will be
displaying below its first any sort of
critical state they will raise up a
little higher on ascending so that
you're able to see it gotcha
and it likes a consolation page where
you're upgrading perches that still in
tax the same thing yeah you go through
and you can hold the menu and kind of
cycle through everything the maps
actually really cool to pull up as well
you are kind of immersed in the world
probably at a thousand foot view looking
at the map and you can move through with
the same control hub Nick ring that up
when he gets out of there
yeah there's a switch somewhere that I
don't know if you hit it or not
someone's shooting there if you get a
two-handed weapon do you hold it kind of
differently I actually Nick once you
kill this guy I'll show you pick up that
longsword that's up on the turn around
real quick this is where I'm gonna make
Nick feel silly once you get rid of that
guy so you have a bow and arrow you
could pull out or you could you can
probably get him with burn slowly but
surely head back down towards the water
okay so this and here yeah so kind of
dip your toes in it to the to the deep
end of the pool and actually Crouch
physically maybe it's not shallow enough
but but for swimming in the game you
actually when you go low sea level you
can Crouch and let's see better here
you're kind of at both levels of the
water okay cool and if you're actually
underwater far enough just like you to
shallow use the triggers and you
actually do kind of a breaststroke Oh
imma came up to swim clear that maybe
when we get outside yeah let me go back
outside that I begun that'd be kind of
fun going over like if you're doing a
Thieves Guild mission and you want to
sneak yeah and the water kind of just
under it I I definitely spent more time
than I need to just kind of like keeping
my head out of the water because it
looks it looks really cool when you do
it an alligator yeah our crocodile art
machine but an alligator works today too
another thing that's awesome
my perspective is that how the this
sides of the screen go dark when I'm
like sprinting or I'm moving around cuz
that helps me like if I'm feeling a
little weird you're like Weezy that that
tightness yeah II feel so much more
focused about what I'm doing
yeah and that's setting you know if
somebody's gonna walk doesn't like that
there's actually a slider that you can
kind of just how that works or turn off
completely if I jump in that River okay
so because of this very flow you'll
still need to swim it might be hard to
swim upstream oh yeah I was too tired
but yeah I look to the right and yeah so
you can just pop like as far as I
remember there isn't a point in Skyrim
where you can kind of get that both
levels where it feels up here I think so
like looking into this is so cool and so
if you can get a little deeper yeah
there's some fish fishy okay if you can
find some deeper water where you feel
like you're not touching the ground
anymore once you're underneath you would
pull both triggers and do exactly what
you try to try a turn around and try
going down the waterfall okay even if
you just have to walk to start with I
think I'm walking yes whitewater rafting
that was great that felt so cool when
you get out of the water Nick can we see
the map yes sir I'm drowning dry off and
uh is this how I swim I think yours I
don't know if you're in deep enough
water to okay so the currents taking you
under and at this point you would want
to make sure your head is you know far
enough below the view yeah now you're up
you're out you made it okay so to pull
up the map hi mr. right triangle on the
left hand your right hand and then you
know just press the trigger in and press
down to map yeah and so the same same
movement you were doing before
applies here so you're just kind of
moving through that beacon of light is
actually where you're presently at and I
said fall crease all right you're right
by river but we have all the holds
unlocked right now obviously as you get
you know there's hundreds of locations
in Skyrim you know all of them are gonna
pop up here and you're gonna be able to
to fast travel as you need to throughout
them you can set markers just like you
would in the main game next and actually
if you as you can see right there we put
a little pointer and show you that you
can show okay where in the world you're
you're looking to target can we go to so
we can go to a hold right now right here
Nick can you put it you have a or no you
can't
we're done you're only gonna why don't
you go to Whiterun it's right by you
yeah right there and then what do i
press to go there they're not you would
press the right move button okay so
press the right move button oh I got
caught you should click so maybe not
maybe we'll just adventure getting it
back I can kill that wolfred Quakers
need to find it where did it go okay
that's another good place to be you
could actually walk towards up like
Falls - you want to see a larger scale
combat in cave
what head up this way okay and DoubleTap
the move to run I think I am right I
can't tell I thank you hey you're moving
pretty quickly
yeah except they have right now Mt I
don't know there's no third person no
third person requested a bill I'm pretty
sure he's wearing the material the
beginning of the game and I know we have
that you know the iron Arlen she's seen
a dragon we all know excuse me ma'am hi
so you don't talk to me though that the
you could start the golden claw clasp by
going in the house there or actually you
can just move around and you know ascend
to old Falls hello
alright so just keep going yeah yeah you
can go wherever you want but uh play to
your heart's content out coming up this
way I would like to go to Whiterun if I
could if that's cool if that's okay yeah
yeah if you want to since I'm looking up
on that that's that'll work I was so
gorgeous
okay so here oh also another question
that maybe you've been asked by fans oh
and I will there be mod support at all
for this being on like there was with
the Skyrim special edition or anything
presently there's no mod support in the
game if it's something that we can
figure out as a possibility we'll let
everybody know but right now it's it's
everything that's in the base game plus
you know all the DLC copy okay cool yeah
what is that so the Dawnguard
I'm Terra man I play all thumbs are hard
fire fire and
Dragon Ball is the one where you
actually go to so makes me happy
there's bringing back memories and
x-rays it does I I think that's one of
the cool things when you when you play
through this is it's like wow this is
all this I know all these things but I'd
never see ya at this before and Whiterun
always reminded me of that Arras from
Lord of the Rings like the Rohan kind of
horse Lord area the Companions quest
line was was my favorite of the kind of
the side quest stuff in the game yeah
you first met anybody because I started
here and double dancin yeah I got to the
werewolf and all that that's bumpy whoo
yeah I was just fun what's the you get
the shield at the end right forget the
guys name his shield that you get from
that tomb yeah and then my favorite my
favorite weapon in the whole game is the
two-handed axe ya rabb that you got it
cosplay house player made one for me
that's pretty hot that axe yeah it's bad
axe era
you're firing on all cylinders instead
they're making me look that I'm usually
not that good with them at all those
nice um you could have more kids and
more plugs have yeah Wow look at that
yeah nice little sq you've got doesn't
like it's cool to me but wow the sense
of scale there yeah big-time
here we go about any other time yeah
even even something like that like
looking up and seeing those archways
like that really you know what we're
seeing right here doesn't do it justice
yeah notice I talked to the yarol
my face thing oh you're good
facing the right way yeah for those
joining we got about another 10 or 15
minutes with Skyrim VR playing on psvr
whether you're going on twitch YouTube
GameSpot or filippo periscoping this as
well
here with Matt Grandstaff from Bethesda
Nick margarita playing over there
oh yes VR with the Move controllers he's
here in Whiterun people are suspicious
of him what did you do you know keep
backing away they just make yourself put
your hands up you can actually or you
can fus-ro-dah her oh uh just use the
Move control so yeah yeah talk to the
girl it's just suspicious right now it's
understandable this guy with a with a
headset on with flashing lights walk in
the room if Nick margarita walk in might
be suspicious he's got that look about
yes you are all girl all girls
everything
yes sir I did I forgot sorry saying oh
yeah yeah we uh Matt and I don't have
audio all right
we can imagine yeah Nick's making the
sarcastic or song kinda looks like he's
won today over I'm gonna leave see ya
check you later and now Oh something
funny you could do you can leave them
with uh you do have your wait we've
unlocked the dragon shouts oh why don't
you just mess up their pool or yeah just
the table not them right you can do it
but if you just want to knock the table
over oh wait a wafer to recharge on that
Oh luckily he went to the play setting
that didn't get anything knocked over so
he's not pissed hey hey what say yet oh
wait yeah it's got a recharge I will
teach something outside that I spared
for today yeah huh you're sparing that
guy for now it's only the community it's
I'm flying so yeah you're getting that
black ring around the division when
you're gonna - as is you're doing direct
movement oh yeah thanks whoa I just felt
like like a sense of fear of heights no
Heights yeah hey no sir
I think it's now wanted me think is
going down the renegade roof with this
character get out here
oh god there are many of them oh sweet
your life your your leveling up as you
as you would we right in my face
probably give them a shout it it's not
the women children shout them oh yeah we
got a hold it hold it longer to get
better though this right you are really
bad I am really surrounded dumb or done
you're bailing you can't even hear us me
Father
are you making fun of me for it all
night useful we're talking about
something the white
this week yeah another good one is the
electric sparks yes the master level
destruction spells are often the
cheapest do this in the game and now
it'll be like standing here whoa there's
a lot of them this is it this was always
the thing and we do have it on a fairly
easy level difficulty got the healing
spell - you'll never get me yeah you do
have restoration if you need it I'm
bailing never coming back to this
community ever you know you know that
that's gonna happen this outages map
shows game shows you know check this out
and then yeah they pick out of the card
right away in the card usually is
overpowered and they just dead in a
couple minutes because you can never
really do there's one thread right there
how nice that was convenient
you never account for wouldn't Nick
margaritas gonna do he's kind of just
the rogue guard can't really send me
you're getting a lot of experience that
is an awful lot of guards right there we
got eight triangle triangle triangle
button left hand I'm gonna try to turn
around do it you're gonna die
you are done they got me oh man the
family way to go down Nick there are a
lot of guards there yeah yes you're like
defense you you uh you broke the law
look but now I get to play with the
sword here yep do your little twisty
twisty the sword
sorry died so that's one death for Scott
oh yeah we got three deaths for doing
one for Scott room probably won't die as
much in this out assume let's just keep
killing innocent you think it's six more
everybody gets a free now we're good I
guess
perfect I wanted to be five yes we do
not have pizza to give you I mean we do
but we don't
Nick can you go Rifton I always like to
rift in a lot I don't know if you can me
uh quickly never mind just do your thang
did you go up through after the deer oh
hey oh wait do your pelts happy
Halloween Nick it's just a terror what
this is you gotta let the people see
there no over here no combat it's all
about since since you have the deer
there you might actually want to check
out the bone arrow as your oh yes
killing all the game out there in the
wild
um mmm my items yes mm-hmm
yep go down weapons and all the way to
the bottom you should see long tho just
kind of keep going
yep oh I don't know if you got it there
and just press one of the move buttons
back out with circle we went through
this before but basically you hold them
both up kind of parallel to each other
maybe like this you use the trick you
can't see what I'm doing but you knock
it back and yeah you probably not toward
an innocent person there was nothing
there I know what is that that is a
butterfly there is no chance I hit the
butterfly we're not giving you free
pizza hundred dollars where you go he's
on the poster thing ah I was playing
yesterday and I cut the butterfly down
with a sword and then just picked it up
and that was just throwing the butterfly
down the hill I knew several things you
can do there's some wolves around here
we'll do a little wolf hunting
yes the Guardian stones so this guy's
down down below just past those stones
so down there yeah no just jump off that
cliff yeah there's a little campsite
over there see it off yonder right there
or there over here
dead ahead oh so you can go sneak so
whole triangle to get into your
sneakiness before I'd let them know
you're coming with a well time [ __ ]
there you go
okay somebody I don't know what you were
aiming for a headshot okay I get a sneak
damage bonus damage right looks pretty
good there oh nice
Oh gonna take more than that it's gonna
take some practice right cuz there's not
an actual crosshair at least we're not
seeing ya you really want to look down
the side of like the tip of the arrow
and look at the angle and that's
everything you know we're training
training you to be oh yeah a real hunter
I like once it's more kinda actual kind
of something you could practice yeah I
mean it's something to wear I've seen
some of them pick it up I don't know if
they ups if they were an archery Andrew
sharp who's the lead producer on the
game is a excellent Archer has taught me
well oh wait sorry like in real life no
no no he's actually Skyrim Archer okay
that's what you good oh wow took an
arrow to the something else
yeah so want to wrap up now right around
now are you want to go a few more
minutes or where any questions you have
or Nick Nick turn your left you're
facing the blue screen right now oh
sorry
it's back we've got maybe another few
minutes
Nick what do you want to do whatever you
would like I can go and look at a nice
Vista you
that closes and you're also crouched
right now so if you hit triangle and are
there we can get again this one relies
slow hit by a giant yeah you can go
fight a giant there outran not really
the farmland South away run uh okay that
voice of God just go
that was John Luke from the back room
what do you say John Luke fight a giant
if you get hit by a giant it launches
you in the air with the physics okay let
me just hit this moose Oh God
if he gets around this woo you're
getting good with the bow that was
excellent
that's true yo what up okay good yeah
there's no stables right by the way yeah
right so no uh yeah there you go you're
just south of there that's where you
meet the Companions speaking of right if
you fight the Giants or you can meet
them there I don't want to get hit right
in their little Hut oh but you know
you're right you think you meet them and
they say come over this way
come yonder it's dead I'm saying yonder
what I yeah Oh Skyrim When in Rome I
think they kind of they usually have a
sarcastic remark like you could hone
your fighting skills more you want to
come join or help us out or something
yeah like go are the Giants like over
there south of way run I thought yeah
south southeast maybe this way right
I thought there we are tower no there
wasn't me right there's there's
definitely one and I guess it depends on
you know your character level in some
cases of where things appear but there
used to be one big garden if I recall
it's East very sorry West if you go west
uh I think you're gonna way yeah I think
I don't want to do this I don't want to
get hit hope you go clients here maybe
not this time I think part of it might
also factor in could be wrong but might
factor to what you've done in the
question yet like we haven't even done
bleep falls yet so what's your left
regular dude your left yeah he's up on
the rock that's just the way run garden
it was as we all know her still not safe
from Nick hi how are you
that cats act that's actually something
I was think I was that answering a
reddit question or something or somebody
was clarifying an interview I did and
they said that I implied that we have
added a virtual waiving of the game and
technically it's true like you can take
your flame hand to just you know hey
what's up you can't you might
accidentally be late someone fire but
you you can tell might happen yeah well
not seeing any Giants boys I apologize
right another time that you are a giant
among men you've done great let's just
stand on this hill and ponder existence
I ponder your existence all the time ah
cool all right so much beauty Nick
thanks for walking us through Skyrim VR
yeah and Matt Grandstaff thank you so
much face and one more time I'm gonna
ask you what's this feel like these
three game